in 1994 the academy awards introduced a
new tradition
the in memoriam section since then the
immemorium portion of the oscars has
represented not just another approach to
the mourning process
but also unfortunately a consistent
source of outrage
some years the controversy stems from
perceived slights against late
entertainers
like in 2011 when the untimely death of
corey haim went
unacknowledged other times the
presentation style
or run time will strike viewers as
disrespectful
and in 2021 in the wake of the 93rd
annual academy awards
twitter users came together to express
their dismay at these two unsettling
tastes coming together
in the form of a segment that they felt
was too short and casually ignored the
death of a beloved film and television
star
the first complaint that social media
users had about the 2021 oscars in
memoriam section
was a boilerplate one the section was
brief compared to other years
in a move that felt flippant to many
viewers some noted that there wasn't
enough time given to each person the
academy was trying to honor
like marvel icon chadwick boseman who
died in august 2020
then there was the issue that fans took
personally beloved actress jessica
walter
who captured audiences imaginations in
play misty for me
and went on to cement her place as a pop
culture deity in arrested development
and archer died in late march 2021
but despite her inarguable place as the
titan of the performing arts
her death wasn't brought up during the
academy awards though she does receive
acknowledgement on the oscars
in memoriam webpage you're the one who
charged his own
brother for a bluth frozen banana i mean
it's one banana michael what could it
cost
ten dollars sadly the late nia rivera
wasn't mentioned during the 2021 oscars
either the glee star drowned in july
2020 while swimming in lake pairu with
her four-year-old son
he survived but rivera unfortunately
didn't
twitter had plenty to say about both
issues one user wrote that the in
memoriam section went by so quickly that
they didn't realize chadwick boseman had
been honored
another tweeted instead of wasting time
with the karaoke thing they could have
made a respectful immemorium with a
decent time speed
elsewhere one user stated those names
went by so fast but did anyone see
jessica walter in the in memoriam
did they just forget her another
expressed their disgust at rivera
not being included saying they are foul
for not putting nia rivera
in the in memoriam one twitter user took
it upon themselves to honor rivera
writing since the academy along with the
grammys decided yet again not to include
nya rivera in the tribute section
of their three hour long show we again
have to do it for them
you're with us forever and your talent
legacy will span
beyond generations check out one of our
newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about the
oscars are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]